foreign
we have called out to the universe
looking for answers
the universe
calls back
[Music]
us your leader
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye I love you I love you
this is new
[Music]
whoa please State the name of your
Homeworld uh first welcome leader of
Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of all
Earth sorry for the mix-up commence
memory wipes
me
I am the leader of Earth why is your
voice different uh I've always talked
like this since I was a kid which I'm
obviously not anymore but yes I run the
planet the trial of Earth can proceed
uh-oh until then as you say on Earth
okay bye I love you okay okay
the talk of the communiverse if Mom
could see me now I know what you mean I
ate my mother at Birth but in moments of
great success I regret it that's a thing
for your species no just a me thing
everyone was shocked
[Music]